peindre entre dans le manoir ici d'un
peu plus près
oserez-vous pénétrer dans la maison
hantée de la famille Calavera la
compagnie Pixum avait investi le manoir
Duar à national des Brévières pour
Halloween petits et grands étaient
invités à déambuler à travers les pièces
et interagir avec des personnages
effrayants on les emmène dans une
aventure avec nous où ils vont déambuler
dans le château et découvrir des décors
très détaillés on est dans un cabinet de
curiosité géant
ça faisait assez peur je suis surtout au
début quand le quand l'homme nous
accueillait dans la maison du style très
coloré du dia de los muertos mexicain à
l'esthétique édouardienne du début du
20e siècle de semaine et une trentaine
de personnes auront été nécessaires à
l'installation de ce spectacle immersif
intitulé La maison hantée From Hell With
Love merci beaucoup de partenariats
notamment avec la Ressourcerie ce que
notre projet c'est de faire du théâtre
écolo donc on fait que de l'objet de
récup on achète très très peu d'éléments
de décor et on est en partenariat avec
eux pour faire de la valorisation
artistique de leurs produits et nous on
fait nos valorisation écologique de
notre projet en même temps donc c'est
donnant donnant avec eux bon
quelqu'un voudrait une petite coupe une
coupe de cheveux non le travail des
comédiens mais les canevas narratifs et
improvisation lors des échanges avec le
public j'ai beaucoup aimé
l'interactivité avec les avec les
comédiens le fait que ils embarquent à
la fois les enfants et les adultes avec
des décors fabuleux de très beaux
costumes et des animations riches sur
évidemment le thème Halloween environ
1200 spectateurs ont fait le déplacement
pendant les trois soirées organisées
fort de ce succès la compagnie Pixum
envisage de renouveler l'expérience
macabre l'année prochaine
[Musique]